je me disais que je pourrais vendre mes
parts
dans ton mariage moi tu m'as pas
comprendre toi la tienne elle t'a tout
laissé elle est morte j'ai pas eu cette
chance
pas si tu veux maintenant tu es
Mannequin alors ben non je suis acteurs
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
mais tu fais le mannequin maintenant le
cintre je dirais plutôt
tu me donnes quel âge
tout le monde à la rue c'est ça que tu
veux on était à ça d'arriver tu te rends
compte de la merde dans laquelle tu nous
mets
est-ce que tu crois que ta gueule elle
vaut plus que la mienne t'es pas bon en
shift tu es pas bon en expression c'est
bon ou quoi exactement
on est amitié
c'est ton pote lui
je connais pas il me colle depuis tout à
l'heure